The Joe Rogan experience.
Oh,
they're all assholes.
Teenage boys.
This gets shit on me.
My friend Eric said,
it's my friend Eric Crisp.
He said it to me once.
He's like,
you know,
because uh,
he was dealing with some teenage boys in his hometown and he was like,
the teenage boys are the most fucking dangerous animals on the planet because
they have all this testosterone.
No one's really giving them any guidance yet.
They're sort of just out there wild and they're trying to outdo each other one
up each other,
you know,
and then they're,
they're cruel,
they're cruel.
And they also are insecure.
And so one of the ways to combat that insecurity is to try to make someone else
feel like shit.
It's like,
it's some weird natural instinct that people have.
Well that,
that is,
that's what gossip is.
Hatred.
Gossip is mild hatred and go sit when you say so and so they're less that you
lower their standards,
you low there,
uh,
respect or the value or whatever by saying something.
Or You could do it as an action.
And in doing so,
you raise your own saying,
at least we're not them because they are shitheads sure less than us.
And that is a,
that has gone on since the dawn of time,
unfortunately.
Well that's where you see the social currency of today is like shame climate,
like shaming people for this or that are attacking people for whatever various
things to do and trying to get public shame against people.
But especially people that haven't really done anything wrong.
What they're doing is they're trying to do that to elevate themselves and they
see someone in the public eyes,
he's someone who's famous or rich and they're saying that person's a fucking
loser.
And there,
you know,
it was sports figures and perfect example,
like some super athlete and they drop a ball,
you fucking loser.
You know,
they're,
they're doing this to sort of maximize this sort of this like this downfall,
this,
if they see anything that's going wrong with that person's life and if they can
accentuate that and pump it up,
but somehow or another they think it elevates them,
it actually does the opposite.
It's terrible for them.
It's terrible for everybody,
but they have this natural instinct,
it's competitive instinct to push down the person they think is elevated to
high.
Well,
I think that leads you to the trolling thing online that if you can do from
behind a firewall of no one knows who I am.
And,
and I remember there was something,
we have bank notes,
like your bank notes that had a woman on the back of one of our bank notes,
the Queensland pictures on the front,
and then they change it up every few years.
And they,
they took the woman who was on the back of it,
I think it was a 10 pound note or something.
They took her off and they changed it.
And then there was this campaign,
we need to get a w and a woman on the back of another different motives.
Not gonna be that.
And two people,
uh,
troll this,
I think to him and saying,
you should die.
He'd be raped.
I mean,
hellish stuff.
One of them turned out to be a woman who was actually attacking another boom
that you think or what's going on in your head.
Where's that coming from?
But behind this firewall you can,
you can go to any place of also,
it's almost like they don't think that a person that they're attacking online is
an actual person.
They're not the social cues from them to not looking at them in their eye.
Yeah.
I just think it's a piss poor way to communicate with people.
I don't,
I don't do any communicating with people online.
I don't go back and forth with people on Twitter,
the back and forth.
I don't,
I don't comment on things.
I don't know anything.
I S I talked so fucking much as it is doing this.
I'm like,
I've said enough.
I know.
If you don't know how I feel about things,
Jesus Christ,
have you listened to this God damn podcast?
That's me.
All right.
I don't need to comment on other shit.
I definitely don't need to comment in text form back and forth with the person
and try to explain myself or just no benefit in it.
I used to,
when I was doing stand up in the clubs and paypal might shout out,
fuck all of you.
Ah,
so you know from the front and I thought,
well,
you're drunk,
you're an idiot.
What am I don't care.
And I would not think that person really knows what they're talking about.
So I wouldn't go into a thing.
I would try and destroy them with,
you know,
put you on some stuff.
Yeah.
But that's what's happening online.
If someone's coming to you and I,
and I used to not worry about it before and suddenly I was worried about,
I don't know.
I actually,
I'm,
I'm not worried about that.
It's just literally like thousands and millions of hecklers.
Yeah.
That's really what it is.
It's a heckling thing.
Some of the,
I came up,
the last one I did with somebody,
I said something and someone says,
Hey,
is Eddie is a fuck you.
And I wrote back,
no,
fuck you.
It was a very witty response.
That's like five year olds as they say.
Yeah,
you're a loser.
You just,
yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
He was the loser and I'm better connect.
So stupid.
You never really feel good about it.
Even if you get a real good zinger on somebody,
just like,
what am I doing with my life?
Yeah.
There was uh,
eh.
Yeah.
My Dad's bigger than you at that thing.
That's what was going on.
And my dad wasn't terribly tall,
so I could have used that.
But what does it matter?
It does,
yeah.
And does that really,
you work for him now?
He keeps bumping into stowaways.
Where do you guys,
it's much too tall.
My Dad.
Yeah.